hey guys Pete here I was talking to a
friend today who is a casual game of
thrones viewer and the conversation came
down to some of the big scenes that hook
you into following the series as someone
who has been interested and immersed in
the lore prophecies in history behind
all of what's going on in Westeros it
was cool to look at things from a
different point of view so today I
decided to make a video about one of the
things that we both enthusiastically
agreed upon and that is that Starks
really know how to get themselves killed
in dramatic fashion these are the top
five stark endings or deaths that we've
seen game Thrones with one exception one
of my favorite stark family deaths
happened before Robert's rebellion so
even though it didn't end up in the show
they did make a clip for it that they
put on a DVD number five Rickon he was
the youngest of Ned and Catelyn skilled
Rijn Rickon travelled north with bran
when they left Winterfell eventually he
went into hiding with OSHA before bran
Meera and Jojen went north beyond the
wall
well John umber gets ahold of him
beheads his direwolf shaggy-dog and then
turns him over to Ramsay snow I don't
think many with the many thought he
would make it out of this predicament
intact and when this scene opened I knew
it was time to say goodbye to a would-be
king of the north
number four John you know Starks and
masters of dying when John snows and
ranks fourth on the list it actually
could be number one based on the
midseason controversy it led to and not
to mention all the anticipation of what
was to come i ranked it at number four
primarily because it happened in season
five and by that time even non book
readers understood that no characters
are safe the other reason it's not at
the top is because I think a good
percentage of viewers knew that he
wouldn't stay dead John is honorbound
and always tries to make decisions that
will help more than just himself that
makes this next thing an even harder to
watch it's one of the wildlings you
brought back says he knows your uncle
Benjen
says he's still alive are you sure he's
talking about Benjen said he was first
Ranger
said he knows where to find it
Unser's II saw your uncle hard-on lots o
woman could be lying
could be no ways to find out where is he
over there
watch
holy
for the wash
number three Rickard and Brandon this is
my personal favorite stark family ending
but I had to rank at third since we
didn't get to see it in the actual show
Rickard is the father of Ned and Liana
and Brandon was their firstborn older
brother the clip is from the DVD extras
that were released with season 1 and it
does a pretty good job of explaining
what happened I liked it so much because
of the impact it had on Westeros before
everything we have seen happen in the
show also the mad Kings blood runs
through Daenerys and John's veins which
is something to keep in mind Lord
Rickard stark continued to serve his
King faithfully as warden of the north
the proud father of four children
his daughter Leona was engaged to Robert
Baratheon the young Lord of storms end
centuries of peace between the north and
the Iron Throne ended the day Rhaegar
Targaryen Prince of Dragonstone abducted
Lyanna enraged Brandon Stark rode to
King's Landing demanding the release of
his sister and the death of Rhaegar
Aerys arrested him for treason and
called his father to come to the capital
to ransom him when Lord Ricard complied
air is now utterly mad arrested him for
treason as well Lord Rickard demanded a
trial by combat Aerys declared fire the
champion of House Targaryen and had Lord
Rickard suspended from the rafters of
the throne room while pyromancers lit a
blaze beneath him as he burned
Brandon was brought into the throne room
another cord attached to a strangulation
device was wrapped around his neck
errors told Brandon his father was a
dead man but there was a chance to save
him a longsword was placed on the floor
just out of Brandon's reach and the more
he struggled to reach it the more of the
cord tightened around his throat Brandon
stark strangled himself trying to free
his father who was roasted alive in his
own home number two Robb and Catelyn I
still remember when I first saw this
episode and how shocked I was after the
fact I came back to watch it by myself
late at night after being out and
remember sitting there thinking that I
just needed someone to discuss it with
after it was all over I still hadn't
read the books at this point so I was
completely unaware that it was going to
happen which made this scene even more
epic
good water you don't want light enough
let it ends please
here's my son my first son let him go
and I swear we will forget this I swear
it by the old gods and new
we've all taken no vengeance you already
swore me one oath right here in my
castle
you swore by all the gods your son would
marry my daughter take me for our six
but let Robb go rub get up get up and
walk out please be and why would I let
him do that
on my honor as a Tully on my honor as a
stock let him go or I will cut your
wife's throat
I'll find another
mother the Lannisters send their regards
and number one Ned this is the first big
one and the mother of the mall as far as
I'm concerned this is another scene that
I can I can remember seeing the first
time like it was yesterday in the time
between when Joffrey says bring me his
head and the deed is done
I remember my brain frantically
searching for some way that Ned would be
able to get out of it I couldn't fathom
that he was actually gonna Dyson so I
would just spent nine episodes getting
to know him and assumed we'd have many
more from there on you know as Arya
shuffling around on the statue of Bale
or I'm thinking there's nothing she can
do why are you showing her show us how
he's gonna get out of this show us how
he makes it out but alas it wasn't meant
to be
I was already hooked on the show before
the scene but after was a dedicated fan
for life so long as I'm your king
treason shall never go unpunished sir
Ilyn bring me his head
don't
so those are the top five stark family
that's an order as far as I see it let
me know in the comments which was your
favorite and why
of course Liana's death in season six is
an honorable mention but it didn't make
my list because that's sort of the way
I've always known her her death is more
of a side note to John's birth in a way
so even though it was a great scene it
just seems different just want to add
one more thing about the stark
direwolves when I went back to pull the
clip for the red wedding I watched the
gray wing part and then that is just too
depressing to put in a video if you
haven't seen my diary Wolf's Theory
video check that out instead it's
definitely more enjoyable please like
the video and make sure you subscribe
I'm having a giveaway when I hit 18,000
subscribers and all you have to do is be
a subscriber and leave a comment I
picked up an extra copy of the night of
the seven kingdoms and will be sending
that out to a random subscriber once we
hit that mark thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon